rue du faubourg saint denis en plein
coeur de little india ici les sarries
color la vitrine c'est le quartier
préféré dans ce joli elle est née en
france mais ça mérite indienne et à lui
a transmis sa passion du cinéma indien
avec sa troupe anjali propose ses
services pour des mariages ou des
soirées privées leurs sources
d'inspiration les films de bollywood ses
comédies musicales de près de trois
heures tourné à bombay aujourd'hui avec
son ami danseuse johanna elle cherche
des accessoires pour un prochain
spectacle
monsieur spécialise dans le bollywood
donc il fait des répliques de vêtements
bollywood est par exemple des costumes
aussi de danse classique on peut choisir
carrément son petit haut il a plusieurs
modèles habitué du quartier anjali
connaît bien le couturier aujourd'hui
elle vient récupérer une tenue et à
paris comme à bombay on choisissait sa
rive de la même façon la mode passe
toujours par bollywood
tous les clients apportent leurs propres
photos des photos comme celle de
l'actrice a choisi arraï tout le monde
demande la même chose je fais les mêmes
modèles avec les mêmes finitions tout le
monde est content
d'une boutique à l'autre les filles
cherchent de nouveaux sari pour un duo
qu'elles veulent monter mais attention
quand on fait de la danse indienne les
critères sont bien précis ça peut-être
que ça brille parce que
tout ce qui dort et tout ce qui brille
c'est un symbole de richesse
les vêtements sont magnifiques les
acteurs sont magnifiques
dans un monde où tout le monde il est
beau
il n'y a pas de lait au niveau un peu
plus loin dans la rue yonge ali fait le
tour des vidéo clubs à la recherche de
nouvelles idées pour son show
la mini vous n'avez pas quatre pour
trouver son bonheur elle a le choix près
de 900 films sortent chaque année des
studios de bombay et on peut tous les
trouver ici quelques semaines après leur
sortie en inde pour anjali pas question
d'acheter n'importe quoi elle ne parle
pas il dit les sous titres sont
obligatoires
tout est filmé ça existe là sous-titrés
français si c'est quelque chose que la
peluche et sow et c'est pas bon du tout
et de passer informatique et et c'est
pour ça serait mieux si quelque chose
cela existait la force et s'est
directement la france et c'est lui qui
porte tout le monde moi je les regarde
en fait en sous-titrés anglais sauf
quand je sais que c'est une bonne
version et c'est bien sous titrée en
français mais sinon c'est carrément
du n'importe quoi fonds comprend rien
c'est du petit n'importe quoi il ya un
an le sous titrage carrément lui mélange
d'hindi d'anglais de duc thinh à gauche
sais pas quoi angeli est déjà allé en
inde à plusieurs reprises elle est
devenue bollywood maniaque elle connaît
cette industrie sur le bout de ses
ongles vernis de long les bacs de dvd à
1 euro elle se faire le tri
bon livre ou le sait l'industrie de
bombay et hollywood hollywood et
bollywood sont les industries puce donc
money woods c'est là
tamouls qu'hollywood c'est le quart à la
tôle et boots et l ogooué donc voilà a
little india on trouve de tout ce qu en
jalles il ne dit pas c'est que plus de
la moitié des dvd ici sont des copies
difficile d'ailleurs de trouver un
vendeur qui acceptent d'en parler face
caméra à quelques mètres de là mais ce
que shiva lui vend des dvd au kilo pour
le prix d'un cheeseman et ne s'en cache
pas
les copies on copie les films il
disparaît et on les loue pour une 1 1 ou
2 jours c'est illégal la police l'a déjà
condamné deux fois peu importe
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un gros problème
pour info une amende peut monter jusqu'à
300 mille euros et en cas de récidive on
ferme boutique où on passe par la case
prison
[Musique]
le soir même à asnières-sur-seine nous
retrouvons anjali rendez vous chez elle
avec les danseurs de sa troupe ce soir
ses plateaux télé ensemble ils vont
décortiquer des films bollywoodiens à la
recherche de nouvelles chorégraphies
on n'est pas obligé de copier pile
il faut
il ya des choses qu'on peut mettre en
attouchements toussaint loi parce qu'il
ya dans ces shows parisiens comme dans
les films de bombay anjali respecte
certains codes ici pas de french kiss ce
n'est pas politiquement correct
s'arrêter là oui sinon où je le tas
comme ça voilà voilà ou juste se
rapprocher mais vraiment on va pas de
gérer la caméra elle va tourner et puis
ça s'est arrêté là
c'était du bollywood light pas question
de se prendre pour des stars animer les
mariages et les soirées privées ça leur
suffit
prochain spectacle dans un mois il va
falloir encore répété
[Musique]
non